how they were Steve coffin here again  just a quick quick video here just to  mention that we're having a great time  in our link Academy live with our three  students who are interacting with us and  learning and we're filming it and so  forth or the other day we had a barbecue  party at the office the students are  interviewing me so you might want to go  over and have a look at these videos I  think you might find it interesting i  will leave some links here in the  description box link academy live a very  interesting experiment in sort of  language learning reality a reality show  built around language learning go and  have a look bye for now